cette semaine il y at il des conflits
territoriaux culturelles économiques
entre les nations et communautés
autochtones au québec
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone si
ses militants alors cette semaine j'ai
la question de chanteurs et c'en est une
alors les conflits territoriaux culturel
économique
la meilleure manière que je peux
expliquer c'est est ce qu'il ya des
différences culturelles économiques
territoriales entre laval montréal puis
longueuil où c'est la même chose
les profanations eux aussi avaient des
conflits entre nations
eux aussi avaient des échanges
économiques des fois marchait pas au
marché il y avait des alliances qui
présente nation d'ailleurs une des
alliances les plus discutés je pense
c'est celle qui avait les français les
anglais et crimes wac et les hurons les
algonquins alors ça souvent était le
conflit historique dont on entend le
plus parler mais aujourd'hui ce que vous
voyez une guerre entre les algues hockey
et les morts non parce que par le passé
on a aussi vécu des choses ensemble donc
ça là aussi rapproché des nations
d'avoir la colonisation d'avoir les
effets de la colonisation mais ça
n'empêche pas que malgré tout avec le
droit canadien avec les les codes il
passe en cour suprême et qui délimite
certains territoires de façon très
linéaire ce qui n'était pas le coche les
premières nations autrefois on avait des
limitations beaucoup plus jeu très
élastique
parce qu'on partage et des fois les
mêmes territoires de chasse on veut
respecter dans le fond la territorialité
de certaines nations on pouvait aussi se
dire écoute je pensais la cdu collègue
louis puis des fois où ce que on se
chicanait des fouilles avaient des
famines qui faisait que les gens se
disputaient les ressources alors
l'humain est en l'humain et oui il y en
avait il y en avait des conflits en est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs que vous pouvez
voir dans les nouvelles soient signés
parce que
pour avoir le droit d'accéder à des
ressources les premières nations doivent
être consultés dont en consultant une
communauté et on en consultant pas une
autre on peut créer des conflits entre
nations là un décor que vous devriez
vraiment suivre présentement c'est le
cas des oueds souhaitait la nation au
dessus et elle est présentement / ce
qu'on emmène division du leadership où
on parle du leadership des conseils de
bande et du leadership des chefs
traditionnels donc en ayant
l'acceptation de certaines communautés
ce passage du pipeline
quand on a une nation un site qui dit
non est ce que ça veut dire que parce
que toutes les autres les autres
communautés ont dit oui tu peux faire
passer en temps cette nation le nom
c'est aussi des territoires familiale
donc tu peux imaginer que même à
l'intérieur d'une nation il peut y avoir
des conflits des débats des enjeux
économiques ou territoriale culturel
donc traditionnel pot traditionnel c'est
assez compliqué mais là ça te demande de
faire de la géopolitique et je pense
qu'on a juste trois minutes pour faire
des chroniques alors juste dit oui
historiquement comme n'est pas interdit
nation il y avait des conflits chez les
premiers peuples et malheureusement on
peut juste essayer de les régler et de
s'entendre les uns avec les autres
alors merci pour ta question chantal je
vous souhaite une bonne semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager une vidéo et
surtout n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions